courage courage and F would you
[Music]
mind sure I'm an rosini the producer of
Winter's B Deborah granik the
director what has been the most exciting
part about year so far uh today yeah
today uh my son took an hour and a half
long nap and so now I know he's good
he's good while I'm gone that's what
pretty exciting yeah oh God yeah I mean
today I think the fact that it stopped
raining and that no one had any trouble
getting here so that all our friends are
here
and become where are you in this journey
how long going it take you to come here
oh about that time yeah we've been
working together for almost 10 years so
yeah Yes sounds about
[Music]
right
not
we got distribution I mean we had an
amazing distributor take on this film
and take the risk of putting this film
out into the world and and we wish that
for every uh independent filmmaker have
that that opportunity to get their film
out you know so much of it his luck and
timing you know there happened to be a
young man in the room representing his
Distribution Company who had a visceral
feeling about our film and his
company you know convened they felt
similarly they took the risk you know we
didn't know that we would get a chance
to meet you know those particular
risk-taking Distributors at that
particular time you there is a chain of
events the first couple reviews matter
so much that's something that we do
that's some some there are many outside
forces that contribute to whether a film
can get here or not so it's interesting
it's a huge amount of fate and
[Music]
luck
we think it's great we think it's great
it's not an easy Road more power to
them I think for us it was a huge relief
to have someone who knows how to do that
it's an art form itself so for us we
would that would have been a devastating
condition for us our film would have
been very very you know insular because
we needed this
experienced talented distributor to
actually show us how it's done plus we
need to make another film so yeah need
to move on
[Music]
yeah oh goodness the well we we're
really huge huge fans of Restrepo and
the work that those two gentlemen do and
um the work that National Geographic
does with their documentary films so we
I think we'd be um really happy to get
in on some of that action
yeah thank you
her